We've done a lot of work so far on
weather scenarios for San Francisco and
for Los Angeles.
I put forward to you this probability
model - some of you say it's not very
realistic.
Quite right! This is a teaching example.
These are the probabilities because they
suit me and that's what I say they are. But
what we did last time was to say if you're
worried that these could get distorted
in transmission
what's the best thing to do? What's the
easiest thing to do?
Well, the easiest thing to do -- I introduced
you to this idea of a checksum digit at
the end.
What it meant was that so long as only
one of these bits got distorted in
transmission you had a lovely situation
of, if you like, "good codes". But if you
said hmmm!,  one bit gets distorted as
long as it's only one bit out of the three
you could end up with something like
this: 0 becoming a 1. You receive 010
that's not in the list of valid codes
- there's an error has happened there
and I think I covered also the fact that
you may know that there is an error there.
This could arise in two or three
different ways but you don't know how it
occurred. But at least it's nice to know
that an error did occur. And at the very
end of the last discussion we said, well,
if you want to say to San Francisco:
"I didn't receive your data correctly" you
could send either an "Acknowledge" or a
"Not Acknowledge" signal. And I postulated
to you that we might decide that an
Acknowledge signal to send back to San
Francisco, meaning I got your three bit
code it makes sense to me; I got 000; It's
foggy; Wonderful! I like it! If that is
the case send back a zero. On the other
hand if I received a 010. It's not in this
allowed set of codes,
I would send back what's technically called
a NAK, and we use a 1 bit for that. And
Many of you said:
"What would happen if these
acknowledgement codes got clobbered on
their way back to San Francisco?!"
"How on earth would you then cope?" Well,
armed with what we know now, the simple
approach instead of Acknowledge being a
single 0 will make it a double zero.
Instead of "Not Acknowledge" being a 1
let's make it a 11.  If one of
these gets altered you might get a 10
you might get a 01. Similarly, here, if
just one bit of those gets altered you
could equally end up with 01 or with 10.
You expect if you're back in San
Francisco to either see a clean double
zero or a clean double one. If you get these
you know that an error has occurred in
transmission.  But, as ever, you don't know
how it occurred.
Was it a distorted "Acknowledge" signal or
a distorted "Not Acknowledge" signal.
Now this could go on forever, if we're
not careful, y know San Francisco
sending back to Sacramento
"I've got a Not Acknowledge on your
attempted Acknowledge signal". You just ...
... it's not good.
What you'd really like to do here - and this
is a very useful lead-in for me to lead
into Hamming codes -
let's see how we can build up a slightly
more sophisticated system,
adding one extra bit more. If you do that
you can not only detect that an error
has occurred but you can actually
correct it.
This gentleman, Richard Hamming, comes
slightly after, I think, the person I've
mentioned already - the great Godfather of
Information Theory,
Claude Shannon. So those are the two big
names around about this era.
Shortly after the Information Theory and optimal
codes, and so on, but in noiseless conditions,
Claude Shannon. A few years later comes
Richard Hamming saying: "How can we detect
errors and, more to the point, how could
we begin to correct to them?"
You've put this on a plate for me because
I can discuss it in terms of how to get
an ACK and a NAK back to San Francisco
so that you can decide and correct
it, if it gets clobbered?.
From now on the ACK will be to send
three zeros. Tthe NAK will be to send
three ones. Suppose you send three.
Why is that magic? What does it do?
If it's a 3-bit pattern that you're
sending, then if those get varied for any
reason of noise,
the total number of combinations in
three bits - as we know off-by-heart now, is
2 to the power 3:  eight combinations.
Let me just pluck out of thin air
the idea of representing those eight
combinations possible, as being the
corners of a cube.
Let me not go through the algorithm for
creating a Hamming code but just pluck it
out of thin air, as I'm so fond of doing.
Let's call this one, up here, our good
code of 000.
Let's call this one - at the back lower
corner of the cube - 111. So that one, if
you like, is representing ACK.
This one is representing NAK. So, so long as
your properties of your [telephone] line were
such that errors were relatively
infrequent, and you got mostly
one-binary-digit errors, then fine.
Here's what would happen. You might send
000 and it ended up as being received
as 010 - the middle bit got damaged.
You might send a 111 and it got received
as a 110 - a one got into a zero.
You might, for example, have sent three
zeros that I'll represent over here but the
left hand
bit got hit and became looking like a one.
Here's 101.
This one is 001 and this one down the
bottom is 011.
Let me just circle - these are what was
actually transmitted.
So, can you see that what you are now in the
lovely position of being able to say is:
if I received three zeros that's bound
to be good.
Similarly if you see 111 trust it. It's a NAK
But if you receive a 010 what then should you do?
The rule is "maximum likelihood", if I can
spell that, or "nearest neighbour"
correction. You can correct what you've
received by saying the following: I
received 010
I know that that is not on my list of
good codewords because the only good
ones are 000 and 111.
What's the most likely way to correct
010 back into being something good?
Well, the answer is by going up this line
here, that's distance one away,
I change the middle bit back to zero
and I've corrected it to 000. If
I receive 001 the most likely thing
that's happened - with only one error
taking place - is that the trailing zero
here got damaged into a one.
So, my correction should be like this
go distance one along the cube's edges
like that. 100 corrects back to 000.
Now, same thing again look, the majority of the
bits here - 110, two out of three, match up
with 111. Therefore my best and
most likely correction is to turn the
zero back into a one.
How about 101? Oh yeah, obviously this was
sent and it was the middle bit
that got hit and turned into a 0. So,
correct that one
down here, Finally, over here 011. Again
two-thirds of the bits are correct but
the leading 1 got hit and turned into a 0.
I clearly have to correct to that. So, you
can see - looking at that - that for all of
the six corners of the cube that are not
the good undamaged codes, you have with
nearest-neighbour maximum-likelihood
correction, a distance-1 correction
algorithm. But the final thing to notice
is that, for this to work and you may
remember - going back to my original
example of when you can detect but you
can't correct - the thing there was that the
distance between the good codes was two.
Notice that what we're doing here, now, is
that between these good codes I shall
use yet another colour.
If you want to get from 000 to 111
you have got to take a journey involving
one, two, three steps.
No matter how you get there you can go one
two, three go
one, two, three down there,
the good codes are distance-3 apart.
So, this is the simplest example i can
think of, of what was generalized by
Richard Hamming into being Hamming codes.
The way you actually build them up,
algorithmically, is a bit involved but
let you all look up about this if you
want some more information. Essentially
Hamming codes are really really good, and
absolutely definitive in their time, for
doing distance-1 corrections, OK?.
For coping with things where only one
bit was in error.
Where things get massively
mathematical, utterly fascinating and
deeply involved are the moment you start
saying: "Well, I'd like to correct one bit
but not just in a 3-bit pattern.
How about in a 32-bit pattern". Yeah! OK!
Well, how many different ways can
that go wrong? And how are we going to
keep all of these different 1-bit errors
apart from one another? How can we keep
the good codes well apart in a much
bigger bit pattern? And where things get
pretty hilariously hairy is if you say
Hmmm!  I don't want to correct just one bit
I want to correct three bits, up to four
bits, up to seven bits ... And that gets you
seriously involved in stuff with names
like field theory, rings, groups, cosets
and other lovely stuff like that.